five days ventures and rated pg-13 every
how's it going everybody its Warren and
we have yet another New Avengers in game
TV spot I keep saying that we're going
to get a new TV spot every other day but
so far we've gotten a new one every
single day so far now some of these are
actual TV spots and some of these are
just promotional videos on Instagram but
with a combination of the two of them
we've gotten new footage basically every
single day for about a week now and we
have some new footage in this clip
including some new dialogue by Thanos
I'll break it all down in this video but
a quick reminder I'm doing a giveaway
giving away a life-sized Infinity
Gauntlet and a glow-in-the-dark painting
by Globe I bow if you'd like to enter
for your chance to win all you have to
do is be subscribed to my channel like
this video and comment down below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain I'll talk more
about the giveaway at the end so
interestingly enough this new footage
opens up with Valkyrie now we've known
that she's going to be an in-game for a
little bit now we've seen League toys of
her and we've seen her on posters at
this point but this is the first time
that were actually seeing her in a TV
spot for Avengers in game and it
immediately shows Thor after so it's
very obvious that at some point in time
Thor and Valkyrie are going to reunite
and team-up whether this is Thor going
off and looking for his people that got
away from Thanos attack or the remaining
surviving as Guardians end up on earth
because that's where Thor told them they
were heading anyways either way it's
very clear that Valkyrie and Thor
reunite we also have a brand new shot of
pepper talking to Tony and then we see
fan o says ship the sanctuary 2 and we
see a blue beam come out of it now I've
heard some people say that they think
this is some sort of blast or an attack
but what this is is Fano simply beaming
down from his ship to the surface of
whatever planet he's on because we have
seen trailers where Thanos does in fact
beam down on the planet where this big
fight happens early on in the movie and
then we very briefly see some footage of
the Avengers and Thanos fighting and we
get some brand new very important
dialogue from Thanos he says to the
Avengers after I kill you I'm going to
burn this
annoying little planet to cinders so he
could be talking about Earth from
multiple trailers and TV spots we've
seen this battle that takes place in the
very beginning of the movie several
times and no one can really make out
what planet they're on there is just so
much destruction in the background and a
lot of people speculate that this
actually could be the destruction of the
Avengers headquarters however we do know
that the Avengers go off into space in
the very beginning of the movie in
search for Thanos so it's also widely
believed that this planet could simply
just be another planet that's far away
but in this new line that Thanos says it
does seem like they're on earth because
he's talking directly to the Avengers
who are from Earth telling them that
he's going to burn this planet that
they're currently on to cinders because
of how annoying it is meaning how
annoying the people from it are because
with the exception of the guardians
everybody from Earth are the people who
tried to stop him from obtaining the
Infinity stones so it is looking like
this planet where all the destruction is
in the background is Earth so the
initial fight could take place with
feyo's attacking the Avengers
headquarters on earth we get a very
brief clip of Captain America not too
different from what we've seen before
but we do get this new clip of Iron Man
he just got hit by one of Thanos's
attack any falls to the ground we've
already seen that Iron Man gets new
armor in Avengers in game and it seems
like that's not enough to take on Thanos
which means he probably still has the
Infinity Gauntlet and even if he doesn't
Thanos is still a very very powerful
being who could probably take on Iron
Man without the Infinity Gauntlet most
of us believe that the Avengers
initially fight Thanos in the beginning
and lose and it seems like that is
what's going to take place in the
beginning of Avengers endgame so that's
it for this new TV spot let me know what
you think about it in the comments down
below and if you haven't seen it yet I
just released an Avengers in-game parody
rap just for fun if you haven't seen it
I'll link it up above and another
reminder about my giveaway giving away a
life-sized Infinity Gauntlet and a
glow-in-the-dark painting by globe I bow
and you can also find some of his other
work at glow by beau calm I'll put the
link in the description down below and
of course if you're new to my channel be
sure to subscribe so you can stay up to
date on everything relating to Avengers
endgame in all things Marvel as always
thank you all so much for watching
for your head in Avengers endgame hey
congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it
very nice and dull it took you said it
cost you everything while crying like a
baby now your